if you want to get a monkey off your
back lop buri Thailand is not the place
to go every year on the last sunday in
november the library in a local hotel
sponsors a festival just for the
resident macaque monkeys and there are
lots of them in the Buddhist tradition
the Thai Revere the monkey as a hero
according to legends the monkey Hanuman
and his army saved a God's wife from the
clutches of a demon we believe that
Hanuman never die so he is the symbol of
prosperity and good good luck and ever
since the monkeys of Thailand are free
to roam and don't have to worry about
their next meal every day people from
the town bring them food but on the day
of the festival near the kamir temple
the spread is huge including a colorful
display of fruits and goodies for the
monkeys to choose from and indulge even
statues of monkeys get trays of colorful
food and a bottle of water the sponsor
of all this monkey business mr. young
ute knows how to make an entrance
organizers say the first purpose of the
festival is to feed the monkeys the
chicken what are 2 d's every year a lot
of people many people to the luxury
four-door see the monkey patty
mischievious monkeys get into everything
and on anyone you'll never get them to
sit still that's why sure I was kneeling
down taking picture of a monkey and all
of a sudden amongst white my my
sunglasses off the locals have to deal
with the problems too ladies of all I
just chased them away from properties I
don't shoot them I just scare them we
believe they belong to the monkey god
the main problem is they interrupt our
properties destroy electric wires and
telephone cables they cause problems but
the problems are overlooked and the
people go out of their way to make sure
the revered monkey stay healthy and
well-fed so if you visit lop buri be
sure to have some extra food with you to
share with the local primates when
people come to visit here you could see
you smile on the face and if it's
festival time there's no telling what
they'll have in store
nakia it a bigger than 10 to yeah sure